the future of superhero movies seems
brighter than ever with the sheer amount
of characters in the Marvel Universe the
possibilities are endless of course not
all pitches make it to production and
many projects have fizzled through the
journey from page to screen a movie
featuring the Inhumans was announced by
Marvel Studios in 2014 for release in
November 2018 but it seems like a movie
that Marvel Studios didn't really want
to make what happened according to
numerous reports the film was announced
during a power struggle between Marvel
Studios head Kevin Feige and Marvel
Entertainment Chairman Ike Perlmutter
who at the time was still overseeing the
work of Marvel Studios if you believe
what's been reported his spiky side of
things then the executive also spent a
lot of time getting in the company's way
Feige allegedly spent years putting
heads with Perlmutter over a wide
variety of issues from budget cuts the
hiring decisions when he was still
working as Spidey's intermediary with
Disney Perlmutter reportedly pushed hard
for an Inhumans film to serve as the MCU
answer to the x-men but it wasn't meant
to be
after Perlmutter demanded that the
expensive Robert Downey jr. be written
out of Captain America Civil War Feige
reportedly threatened to quit working
for Marvel unless things changed this
apparently convinced Disney to let him
in Marvel Studios report directly to
them for film making decisions instead
of having to go through Perlmutter and
the wider Marvel Entertainment Company
first once this creative freedom was
secured the Inhumans movie was cancelled
he should have known this day was coming
while Marvel Studios no longer has to
answer to Perlmutter Marvel television
is a different story
which is why the Inhumans eventually
ended up landing on ABC with a
remarkably cheap looking TV show the
worst reviewed project in the entire m
see you before directing the 2 Ant Man
movies Peyton Reed had plans to create a
Fantastic Four film developing his own
pitch for the project in the early 2000s
according to an interview with Collider
the film was going to be set in the 60s
and be totally similar to the Beatles
film a hard day's night notably his take
would have skipped the origin story
instead jumping straight into the action
Johnny
this is torture
[Music]
sadly Fox didn't have much faith in the
project according to read it felt like
they sort of wanted to make a b-movie
out of it so we parted ways
we shall mount a musical of the
Fantastic Four
the Silver Surfer is a cosmic entity who
travels through space on a surfboard at
the speed of light that's already a
pretty weird concept so maybe it's not
too surprising that the character almost
took a left turn into the musical genre
according to Sean House book Marvel
Comics the untold story lee kramer
executive producer for the movie Xanadu
expressed interest in making a silver
surfer rock musical during the 1980s
Kramer said of the project we're going
to make an epic picture on the scope of
2001 a Space Odyssey with a kind of
soundtrack that that film had only using
contemporary rock and roll it's even
conceivable that the surfer might have a
chance or a fanfare made up of 1000
electric guitars the film would have
reportedly starred Olivia newton-john
also fresh off of Xanadu but she wasn't
the only big name attached to the
project Paul McCartney was asked to
contribute to the soundtrack a more
reasonable request than you might expect
considering that the ex Beatle is an
avowed Marvel fan who even wrote a song
about Magneto and Titanium Man
ultimately the project fell through and
we wouldn't see the likes of Norrin Radd
on the big screen until 2007 s Fantastic
Four rise of the Silver Surfer after
that exceedingly bland blockbuster it's
fair to ask could the musical option
have been any good it's hard to say but
hey it couldn't have been much worse
than spider-man turn off the dark made
famous by Scarlett Johansson's portrayal
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Black Widow has become a bigger fan
favorite than ever before for the
self-titled newbie on the way in 2020
but that won't be the first time the
Marvel's tried to show audiences the
backstory of this former spy are you
kidding I'm working I'm in the middle of
an interrogation this [ __ ] is giving me
everything though many people know David
Hayter is the voice of Solid Snake in
the Metal Gear series he's also had a
successful career as a screenwriter in a
2014 interview with latino-review
Hader revealed that he'd written a black
widow script ten years prior and was
even attached to direct the project at
one point hater alleged that the poor
performance of other action
starring women in an era defined by
flops like Elektra and Laura Croft Tomb
Raider was the main factor that caused
Marvel to get cold feet and shelved the
project funny how things can change
throughout the 80s and 90s DC Comics and
Warner Brothers saw plenty of success
with Batman and Superman while Marvel
was having a tougher time but that
didn't deter one actors aspirations of
bringing one of the company's iconic
heroes to the big screen for the first
time in the mid-90s Wesley Snipes was
coming off a string of successful movies
and had a vision for his own superhero
vehicle an adaptation of Marvel's Black
Panther comics but the process proves
more difficult than Snipes had
anticipated he later told The Hollywood
Reporter ultimately we couldn't find the
right combination of script and director
and also at the time we were so far
ahead of the game in the thinking the
technology wasn't there to do what they
had already created in the comic book in
the end Snipes and Marvel teamed up for
a less ambitious project Blade
it's day 1 the 1998 film earned over 131
million dollars becoming Marvel's first
real movie success black panther
meanwhile was still listed as an
upcoming film as late as 2000 with
variety describing the project as a
vehicle for quotes a black indiana
jones-style character to which wesley
snipes has long been attached to produce
and star in 2008 writer Neil Gaiman told
premiere that he had been interested in
creating a film centered around dr.
strange Gaiman approached director
Guillermo del Toro with the concept and
according to Gaiman he was interested in
an interview with Collider game and
explained that while del Toro was on
board the film was likely around four
years from entering production due to
his busy schedule time is the true enemy
of the dawn time kills everything
regarding the project del toral told
Empire that's an interesting character
because you can definitely make him more
in the pulpy occult detective magician
mold and formula and was done in the
weird tales for example the idea of a
character that really dabbles in the
occult in a way that's not ex Philae
where the supernatural is taken for
granted that's interesting but I
wouldn't use the suit ultimately Gaiman
and del toral never got to make their
version of Doctor Strange Marvel wasn't
interested in taking on the project
waiting to introduce the master of the
mystic arts to movie audiences until
scott derrickson 2016 film starring
Benedict Cumberbatch in the early 90s
James Cameron convinced Kuroko Pictures
who backed Terminator 2 Judgment Day to
option the film rights for spider-man
but after the company went under the
rights the Spider Man were purchased by
Sony and Cameron moved on to other
projects like Sam Raimi's 2002 feature
Cameron's spider-man would have been an
origin story with he changes to the
familiar comics lore one notable
creation from Cameron's camp was Peter
Parker's organic web shooters which
would eventually and controversial II
show up in the trilogy that Sony made
this stuff coming out of you Cameron
script was notably more adult-themed
than most takes on the webslinger would
end up being featuring an abundance of
profanity and sexuality including a sex
scene on the Brooklyn Bridge and some
truly distressing spider themed foreplay
after blade and x-men got the ball
rolling
the next Marvel comic hero to take the
world by storm was Tobey
McGuire's spider-man the film was a huge
success earning more than eight hundred
and twenty-one million dollars it
sparked one sequel that remains beloved
by fans as well as another sequel that
isn't WTF to that despite the failures
of the third spider-man Raimi was ready
to set the series right with a four
rumors swirled that the follow-up would
feature John Malkovich and Anne Hathaway
as vulture and black cats but a
satisfactory script never materialized
and the project left Rama's grasp as the
filmmaker later explained it really was
the most amicable and undramatic of
breakups it was simply that we had a
deadline and I couldn't get the story to
work on a level that I wanted it to work
Sony had high hopes for its rebooted
spider-man franchise but when it comes
to critics and box office the amazing
spider-man movies were anything but the
second amazing spider-man was meant to
be followed by a villain centric movie
introducing the team known as the
sinister six it was slated for release
in 2016 with a third spider-man movie
set to follow two years later based on
the first two movies it's hard to be
disappointed that none of this happened
after the second movie failed to
establish a Spidey Cinematic Universe
Sony threw in the towel creatively and
struck a deal with Marvel Studios to get
the webslinger in the MCU
I'm Peter by the way Doctor Strange made
up names
um I'm spider-man then after the first
trilogy of x-men films Fox tried to ship
the focus from teen movies to individual
origins but the only mutant to actually
get this treatment was Wolverine Batman
Begins writer David s Goyer was slated
to write and direct the follow-up
focusing on Magneto
but when audiences actually saw how bad
the Wolverine movie was it effectively
killed the brand in one shot
though the movie was never made
script drafts suggest the story that
would have opened during Magneto's time
as a prisoner in Auschwitz following him
through adulthood has become something
of a Nazi hunter before meaning Charles
Xavier this is where yo Powell was born
and this is where yo people who was
slaughtered elements of the story would
eventually form the core of x-men first
class and it's follow-ups but on the big
screen at least much of magneto story
remains untold check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite comic
book movies are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]